when you look back on uh the work that
you've done i mean this one is
is very specific work it's very unique
but it seems as a viewer that you've
really enjoyed all the roles that you've
been in like it just looks like you're
enjoying yourself having a good time
doing it
what have been the most enjoyable
experiences for you that you've had on
set
i mean they all i just love
getting to do what i do for a living and
and uh and most of the time i really
love
the job and i think
gary [ __ ] you mentioned and that was a
special one for me because i'd worked
with
julian for you know the director before
and so
when he asked me to be involved in that
project i was just delighted because
he's just
he's just great and he's got a radar for
anything that's not good enough like
he's not afraid to tell you something's
not quite
if it's just a bit pony so um
yeah gary hatchy was great we had the
ball and i got to play a character that
i really adored and she was
fun and there was so much drama that
there was so much
so there were so many fun aspects to it
as well and humor because of
it so yeah that was a special one
how often do you get people telling you
that
trainspotting changed their life no i
mean
not that often i mean but what is
interesting about transporting is that
it was the first
my first foray into acting proper
um but it it's also the thing that
people still want to talk about like i
can't tell you how many
you know how many emails i get about you
know will you do this
interview about transporting you know
for whatever anniversary it happens to
be i mean it just keeps on going
and um i don't think there's anything i
could say that i've not said
already about it so yeah it was a big
one
is it is it a surprising it's like that
people still
connect to it now well
yeah i mean we were in it oh
it was my first film experience and i
being on set i'd never been on set
before and i thought every
job would feel have that energy and that
sort of like it was electric um
and i just thought that's working in
film and then
i find out that that's not always the
case it's like we were just really
sort of on the cusp of something in the
uk and danny
made a film that was unlike other things
that had been made before
and then the whole sort of run up to the
release was done in a different way as
well and
it was just very exciting and
[Music]
i forget questions sorry that's right
i think we got it i think you got it
do you you know you've done roles though
you've played these characters that have
connected with people whether it's
merida helen or ravenclaw um
in harry potter do you get a lot of
interaction from fans where they are
saying to you that ever since i was a
kid i've loved
this character and you know disaffected
me in that way do you
get a lot of that interaction no no
i mean um that's nice people
have that i don't really get that kind
of interaction there was a a couple of
years
that um i was getting a lot of attention
from little girls
and you i was in doctor surgeries a lot
it must have been sort of when i was
having babies and stuff like that but i
felt like i there was always
a mum coming up to me in a doctor's
waiting room asking if her daughter
could say hello or um you know and then
the mom would explain
that i was married in them in the disney
film
or that i was in anonymity or
you know i seem to do there's a few
really kid-friendly films that i did and
so that was a thing for a while but i
think i think
teenagers are just a bit too cool to say
anything so maybe that's
it oh they'll they'll just stand off in
the corner and go oh that's her
that's her i'm sorry they'll talk
amongst themselves yeah
that's that's what i'm gonna do yeah
you